- [Instructor] We're told
that Roberto and Jocelyn
decide to roll a pair
of fair six-sided dice
to determine who has to
dust their apartment.
If the sum is seven,
then Roberto will dust.
If the sum is 10 or 11,
then Jocelyn will dust.
If the sum is anything
else, they'll roll again.
Is this a fair way to decide who dusts?
Why or why not?
So pause this video and see
if you can figure this out
before we do it together.
All right, now let's do this together.
So what I wanna do is
make a table that shows
all of the different scenarios for rolling
two fair six-sided dice.
So let me make columns for roll one.
So that is when you get a one.
This is when you get a two.
This is when you get a three.
This is when you get a four.
This is when you get a five.
And then, this is when you get a six.
And then here, let's do the other die.
So this is when you get a one.
This is when you get a two.
This is when you get a three.
This is when you get a four.
This is when you get a five.
And then, this is when you get a six.
So one way to think about it
is this is roll one
or let me write it this way,
d1 and d2.
This could be a one, a two,
a three, a five or a six.
And this could be a one,
a two, a three, a four,
a five or a six.
Now what we could do is
fill in these 36 squares
to figure out what the sum is.
Actually, let me just do that
and I'll try to do it really fast,
one + one is two.
So it's three, four, five, six, seven.
This is three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
This is four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
This is five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10.
This is six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11.
Last but not least,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11 and 12,
took a little less time than I suspected.
All right, let's think
about this scenario.
If the sum is seven,
then Roberto will dust.
So where is the sum seven?
So we have that ones, twice, three times,
four, five, six.
So six out of, so six of these outcomes
result in a sum of seven.
And how many possible equally
likely outcomes are there?
Well, there are six times six
equally possible outcomes or 36.
So six out of the 36
or this is another way of saying
there's a 1/6 probability
that Roberto will dust.
And then, let's think
about the 10s or 11s.
If the sum is 10 or 11,
then Jocelyn will dust.
So 10 or 11,
so we have one, two,
three, four, five.
So this is only happening
five out of the 36 times.
So in any given roll,
it's a higher probability that Roberto
will dust than Jocelyn will dust.
And of course, if neither of these happen,
they are going to roll again.
But on that second roll,
there's a higher probability
that Roberto will dust
than Jocelyn will dust.
So in general, this is not fair.
There's a higher probability
that Roberto dusts.
So this is our choice.